[Musique]
on a dernière fois que x qui était venu
sur le plateau je me rappelle il avait
donné le numéro de faux cadres à gaza
dit regardez qua non excusez moi juste
on peut regarder sur scène mon bureau
j'ai plein de papiers tout vent que j'ai
peut-être un deal à faire dans nos
rations suffit à ccc à 6,6 non il y en a
assez de faire ses blagues qu'il faut
dire que vous sert il
ce soir je vais peut-être me venger et
venger franck il ya quelques mois où les
[ __ ] millions de téléphones et celui
de franck je conseille un cauchemar tout
été collectées chez moi oui donc ce soir
j'ai dépensé une fortune et la prod de
vote prod a dépensé une fortune
mauvaise nouvelle on va balancer votre
numéro de téléphone
d'une façon on n'a même pas idée comment
il va se balancer dans ce sens surtout
qu'elle est klaproth la vie de ma mère
draghi ont freiné mais n'a pas de deal
copenhague odile
jobs alors benjamin donc ce soir à saint
germain enchaîne donc les au téléphone
de cyril hanouna va donc est diffusée
vient à peine de la voir mais diffusée
l'année n'ont pas n'ont pas alors à tuer
ce que je peux vous demander à être est
ce qu'elle veut voir l'image de la
dernière fois on voit l'image et on en
parle à faire toutes ces années j'étais
préparé une petite surprise va regarder
pas déroulées toute la basse déroulé
tout là bas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
proposition à vous faire un bâton il ya
un camion qui est dehors avec la tête de
série et ils sont numéro 6 g en prime
vous je balance le nom de téléphone de
cheryl sur le camion qui va faire tout
parent et une balance parce que c'est
mon vol numéro
maintenant ça va bien on a donné le
numéro de vous
non seulement non seulement je vais
balancer maintenu leur téléphone syrie
non mais d'une façon que toute la france
pour avoir non vous allez voir été
regardé un drame en direct c'est
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non merci
alalalala m emmène au thème belges y
aurait comme un 10-0 à kbc
[Applaudissements]
oh lalala lalala perd bêtement ben
franchement cramer sont encore mon chéri
et en bons numéros
je sais que c'est vrai elle sera pas
avoir internet
merci d'être avec nous on est en direct
bien entendu c'est le prime c'est le
dernier de l'année
[Applaudissements]
chez
[Rires]
je relève m mais
pourquoi je prends encore cette couleur
[Applaudissements]
chérie
ça m'a jamais aventuré on t'aime fort
inquiète pas c'est moi qui m'en occupe
tu vas faire quoi non mais je vais avoir
un numéro de ouf parce que tu l'as dit
oui si je t'offre un sonnet sur mon ipad
sont bondées d'atr j'ai ma mère gemma
search
non mais bon si je te promets un numéro
deux stations personne n'a déçu là
encore vraiment ouais en plus elle
pourra obtenir les numéros là il va
falloir encore un agenda
je vais avoir un numéro de ouf est ce
que tu me fais confiance genre hyper
facile à redonner confiance
cette phrase elle vannes je te ferai
plus jamais confiance center mais je
pense que vous pouvez la voir une
troisième fois ça me fait beaucoup de
peine
benjamin on t'aime on va le laisser tout
remettre de ses émotions